night owls like myself we were just full
of vodka and like nachos or something I
usually go to bed maybe around 1:00
every night between like 12:00 and 2:00
anywhere between at 12:00 and 3:00 a.m.
I wake up for work as late as I possibly
can to still get there on time and in
one piece I hit snooze five or six times
before getting up in the morning I
desperately want to be a morning person
I love the idea of people getting up
like walking their dogs and like being
healthy and eating granola and yogurt I
could be a much more productive person
if I utilize those morning hours I'm
about to wake up early and I'm really
excited but nervous that I won't be able
to do it
hey what's up I do I get up a run like
3:30 every day so our power lifts and I
prefer to train in the morning as
opposed to the evening and honestly it's
a better like more healthy way of living
I have more time in the day I can get
more stuff done I'm not as rushed and
honestly our ancestors lived that way
they woke up with the Sun and went to
bed with the Sun so for me it's the more
natural way of living yeah I would love
to help some night owls wake up early
Monday through Friday you need to be up
by 5 a.m. Saturday and Sunday I would
prefer if you're up by 8 o'clock
rule number two so with the extra time
in the morning do something that you
love to do that you don't normally have
time walking my dog cook a serious
breakfast maybe number three is this is
Sunday night - Thursday night you need
to be in bed between 9:00 and 11:00
Friday and Saturday night 10:00 p.m. to
1:00 a.m. because I know people like to
go out I'm gonna have no life and I
think it started until 10:00 okay let's
get let's get into it I think you guys
can do it I think you'll surprise
yourself another two weeks let's go
I'm going to bed way later than I wanted
to but then I just kind of got away from
me my goal is to wake up tomorrow and
work out before work I'm optimistic I'm
excited I hope that I can do this field
my first name today would you better
come s in the morning oh yeah actually
don't feel bad tired upon a very short
conversation with my boyfriend I
realized I'm in a really bad mood I am
just incapable of communicating properly
with other humans so I had time for a
little bit of stretching in yoga and I'm
also gonna have time to like do my hair
it's 10:00 a.m. on a Saturday much too
early for me so we headed to Starbucks
for some much-needed caffeine and I'm so
cranky about it so I'm at work sleep
gets [ __ ] basically I've been failing
absolutely well no so we're supposed to
get up super early for a breakfast
tomorrow but I'm exhausted we'll see how
it goes I mean I have to do it it'll be
the worst thing ever if I somehow don't
make it I'm absolutely miserable
look there plenty of people out there
are four people here I'm actually doing
chores before the Sun is out what I just
realized the new episode of speed cleans
it's on Hulu so I'm actually gonna try
to catch a little bit of it on myself a
tiny glass boring even though the rules
say I shouldn't I wanted to be just like
my friends on Instagram and I failed
miserably I have been getting up earlier
so in the mornings and more relaxed it's
a better start to the day and I just
feel like I'm in a better mood the first
week I definitely noticed that my body
would be up but my brain wouldn't be up
with me at the same time waking up and
doing something physical and centering
like yoga definitely helped me get both
of my halves
started with today I enjoy my night life
zone
and the fact that conversations would
would just be getting good at like 11:00
and I was already late to bed with kind
of a weird thing I definitely think the
people who consider themselves a night
owls should try waking up earlier maybe
even just by like an hour so it feels
really good to not be rushed in the
morning I'd really like to make this
like a legit life change where I
actually become a real morning person Oh
goodbye night life it's been nice
knowing you I'm gonna start hanging out
with morning moms now